you know I've been doing this radio show
for 25 years plus now and to say that I
have learned a lot during that 25 years
would be a vast understatement I learned
something almost every day some of you
on Twitter are quick to teach me grammar
and we appreciate that I learned
something almost every day I really
really do and I kind of enjoy the
process because I figure if you're not
learning you're dying so when we started
this show many many many many years ago
there was a guy on the air with me there
were two of us that did the show
together he was in the mutual funds
business and in the insurance business
and so when people would call in asking
about investing we would send them to
his office and to say that he made a lot
of money would be an understatement he
did really really well and I had my
securities license at that time and I
had my insurance license at that time
and I had been in those businesses and
the when he left the show some of the
regulator's decided that they wanted to
regulate what what I could say and since
he wasn't on the show well even when he
was on the show they want to regulate
what I could say they certainly can
regulate what you say if you have a
securities license if you don't no
securities to sell stock or to sell
mutual funds it's the most highly
regulated of all industries by far what
those folks are allowed to say or do is
nothing they can't do anything it's
amazing that they can even make a living
the way the government rides their backs
but anyway they decided they were gonna
regulate it and I'm like well I don't
sell mutual funds I'm not the business I
don't sell stocks I'm not in the
business so I just dropped my license
now regulate that yeah good luck and
drop my insurance license the same thing
somebody in the whole life people are
mad at me because something I said about
insurance why don't care I'm gonna sell
life insurance let me give a crap I
don't make any life insurance
Commission's the only license I kept
I've had my real estate license since I
was 18 and I've still got that still a
real estate broker technically speaking
but I'm obviously now they're putting
the signs in people's yards I can tell
you that so I'm no threat to you real
estate people don't worry about it
because I wouldn't even know how to do
the web stuff now to be in that business
but you know so I
okay then this guy leaves and these
people are calling me on the air and
they want to know who they can call to
do their investing with and I thought
well that's a that's an advertisement
opportunity I'll get such-and-such a
stock brokerage firm and you could name
any one of them right a Merrill Lynch or
Ora Ora Edward Jones Ora or or just name
them all right and I won't say which one
I put one of them on and I started
sending everybody they wanted to invest
to them well they were giving them
advice it was like perpendicular to what
I would say do they say you know borrow
on your house and put it all in my
mutual fund and they would say hey
here's a whole life policy for you and
they would say all this stuff so people
were then calling me up mad at me
because I sent them over there to get
advice that was exact opposite of what
I'd been telling them to do so that
could that in last saw fire down drop
that advertiser
okay how are we gonna help these
listeners and that's when the what was
known as the ELP program was born we
thought you know I can't get one certain
company to behave but I can get
individual offices to give advice that's
consistent with what they hear on the
air so that I'm not a hypocrite for
sending you the listener over there and
I will endorse Joe over here in this
city and Jill over here in this city and
Henry over here in this city and they'll
pay me a monthly fee for being endorsed
and they can come to later we got on the
web and they can come back an old days
used to me by the fax you know and so
but they can come on the web and they
can click on there and find out who the
ELP in their city was for investing and
they can go to that and so on well the
the market has continued to become more
and more and more regulated to the point
that now that system doesn't work
anymore and so it died LP investing
endorsing ELP s for investing died at
midnight last night it died it's really
sad moment of silence for the EOP
investing program it's been going for 20
years almost me sending people to get
investing from people that were safe and
trustworthy but good news is something
else was born this morning I think I was
just gonna die did you so when you go to
our website today
is a whole different process and a whole
different name we no longer have ELP
investing we now have smart vest errs we
want you to be smart when you invest so
we're calling it smart investor so have
you seen smart and a lot of our stuff
lately yeah we want you to be smart in a
lot of places so now you're a smart
investor and if you need some help to be
a smart Wester we're going to connect
you with a smart investor Pro someone in
the business to help you with that
sounds kind of like the old system but
it's a lot different really on the
technicalities and how it works
one different one major difference for
you the listener is this and this is so
cool y'all it used to be when you would
click on ELP investing it would cut
you'd fill out a form and that form
would go to one person in your area and
they would contact you immediately and
you could work with them now when you
put in your zip code five or four or
three different smart Wester pros will
pop up in your area and you can choose
which one you want and you click on it
so you get it you get to be involved in
the process of selecting which is cool
for you it's nice and I feel menu thing
there and when you click on that then
you would have the opportunity to give
them your them not me but give them your
information so that you can they can get
in touch with you and you can get in
touch with them and you know you can sit
down get your IRA doan or get your kids
college fund going and so forth so from
this day forth let it be known and
decreed that ELP investing is no more
smart vest errs are what you are and if
you want some help we've got some smart
Wester pros and we have a whole lot more
of them than we've ever had because in
the last 45 to 60 days our team has been
busting their butts to get a whole bunch
more people in the program
that will give you advice that you will
be familiar with it sounds just like
what you hear here because I'm not gonna
send you to somebody for your heating
and air that I wouldn't send my sister
to I'm not gonna send you to somebody
for your car to be repaired in San
Antonio unless we've checked them out
and I feel good about that car repair
place I don't need the money from these
endorsements we make plenty of money and
other stuff endorsements are nice and
they're good but they're there to serve
you guys and so I'm the only major talk
radio
in America the only one of the top five
or six that still does local ads I still
will endorse a heating and air company
in your area a window company in your
area a dentist in your area but we're
highly selective about well how we do
that because we want to protect you and
we want to be able to give you honest
endorsement and it helps that local
small business and I'm a big fan of
small businesses and so if I can help
that guy that runs an honest garage in
San Antonio or in Abilene I want to help
them if I can help that gal that has a
great dental practice I want to help
him/her whoever it is whatever it is if
it's something I believe in I'm not
gonna endorse visa obviously and I'm not
gonna endorse a debt plan for your small
business you know I'm gonna be
inconsistent and I'm not gonna be
inconsistent where I send you for you
know for for investment help from a
smart investor Pro and so you know that
and they'll take your accounts if you
have a small account to and a lot of
people in the business won't take those
anymore because they're so over
regulated they can't afford to write up
the paperwork anymore
the government is so intrusive y'all you
have no idea but we're a new day
smart faster pros cool and you now are
officially a smart buster or you will be
soon this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income a $500,000
in economy
you